THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, HE HAS FOUR KIDS.
THANKS.
>>> THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
AND 17 STATES LAUNCHING A
LAWSUIT AGAINST AMAZON.
THE SUIT ACCUSES AMAZON OF
HAVING A UPONOPOLY OVER THE
RETAIL ENVIRONMENT AND USING
MARKET SIZE AND POWER TO RAISE
PRICES FOR CONSUMERS.
>> PEOPLE ARE PAYING HIGHER
PRICES.
CONSUMERS ARE PAYING MORE, SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE HAVING TO PAY 50%
AMAZON TAX RIGHT NOW, AND SO
ULTIMATELY THE COMPLAINT IS
SEEKING TO RESTORE THE LOST
PROMISE OF COMPETITION, GREATER
COMPETITION MEANS LOWER PRICES,
BETTER QUALITY, BETTER
SELECTION, AND GREATER
INNOVATION.
AND THAT'S ULTIMATELY WHAT THIS
CASE IS ABOUT.
>> THE CASE ALLEGATIONS UNFAIRLY
PROMOTES ITS OWN PLATFORMS AND
SERVICES HARMING THIRD-PARTY
SELLERS WHO RELY ON AMAZON TO
SELL THEIR GOODS.
THE CLAIM HAS FOLLOWED AMAZON
FOR YEARS.
LENA KHAN WROTE ABOUT THIS IN
2017 AS A LIEU STUDENT.
HERE IS HOW SHE EXPLAINED IT TO
US IN 2019.
>> A SITUATION WHEN A SINGLE
COMPANY IS ABLE TO SET THE TERMS
OF THE MARKETPLACE.
THAT'S A SITUATION WHERE WE
SHOULD WORRY ABOUT THE MARKET
NOT BEING COMPETITIVE.
>> THAT YEAR I ASKED THE
THEN-CEO OF AMAZON WORLDWIDE
CONSUMER JEFF WELKE ABOUT THESE
CRITICISMS.
AMAZON'S MARKETPLACE DOMINANCE.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> DOES AMAZON GIVE PRIORITY TO
UNPRIORITIZE ITS PRIVATE LABEL
IN SEARCH?
>> WE PRIORITIZE THE THINGS THAT
CUSTOMERS WANT.
>> A RECENT HEARING ON CAPITOL
HILL AN AMAZON ATTORNEY WENT A
STEP FURTHER AND CATEGORICALLY
DENIED THE CLAIM.
>> WE DON'T USE THEIR INDIVIDUAL
DATA WHEN MAKING DECISIONS TO
LAUNCH PRIVATE BRAND.
OUR INCENTIVE IS TO HELP THE
SELLER TO SUCCEED BECAUSE WE
RELY ON THEM.
>> WHEN WILKIE LEFT THE COMPANY
IN 2021, LINA KHAN TOLD CNN THE
FTC HAS NOT RULED OUT HOLDING
AMAZON EXECUTIVES PERSONALLY
LIVED FOR THE COMPANY'S ALLEGED
CONDUCT IF THEY FIND SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE.
>> AMAZON SAYS IT COULD CAUSE
THE VERY PROBLEMS IS HOPES TO
SOLVES AND, QUOTE, IF THE FTC
GETS ITS WAY, THE RESULT WOULD
BE FEWER PRODUCTS TO CHOOSE
FROM, HIGHER PRICES, SLOWER
DALLAS AND REDUCE OPTIONS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES.
THIS IS NOT THE FTC'S ONLY
LAWSUIT AGAINST AMAZON.
IT'S SUING SEVERAL EXECUTIVES
ALLEGING SCHEMES TO ENROLL
PEOPLE INTO THEIR PRIME
MEMBERSHIPS WITHOUT KNOWING.
YOU HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON THIS
ALL MORNING.
>> DID I EMAIL YOU ENOUGH ABOUT
IT?
>> I LOVE THOSE EMAILS.
I LEARN A LOT FROM THEM.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
BECAUSE 14 A HUGE MOMENT NOT
JUST FOR THE FTC, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, AND LINA KHAN.
>> THIS HAS BEEN HER FIGHT.
SHE IS THE FIRST WHO RAISED THE
QUESTION TO THIS COUNTRY ABOUT
WHAT A MONOPOLY, DO WE HAVE TO
CHANGE THE WAY WE DEFINE A
MONOPOLY FROM THE MICROSOFT DAYS
TO WHAT AMAZON IS NOW.
MY QUESTION IS, IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TRACK 17 STATES ATTORNEY
GENERAL ARE ONBOARD.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR PEOPLE AT
HOME AND WHO SELL ON AMAZON.
IF THEY PREVAIL, IS IT JUST
GOING TO BE FINES AND PENALTIES
OR WILL ACTUAL CHANGES HAPPEN
THAT BENEFIT THEM?
AMAZON, TOO, SAYING IF YOU
SUCCEED IN WHAT YOU ARE TRYING
TO DO, IT'S JUST GOING TO COST
PEOPLE MORE.
IT'S GROUNDBREAKING.
SEE WHERE IT GOES.
>> SEVERAL SUITS THE FTC HAS